cette vidéo c'est Angèle l'agression
d'Angèle 89 ans
Angèle est avec nous ce soir merci
Angèle d'être là
Angèle qui est avec son fils qui était
venu nous voir dans TPMP René
merci d'être là René merci d'être là
vous vouliez absolument être là ce soir
merci
René on essaye on espère qu'on va
pouvoir faire avancer les choses ce soir
parce que on a été extrêmement de votre
agréé
tranchement
dans la rue ces jeunes
dans la rue
on a plus le droit de les éduquer avant
on allait à l'école on se prenait un
coup de pied au cul ou une gifle ça
jamais tuer personne mais pour les
suivre ces gens il faut il faut arrêter
là ça va plus là ça va vraiment plus là
si ils sont dangereux ils deviennent
dangereux est-ce que vous avez vu le
coup que ma mère elle a pris est-ce que
la force de l'agression mais c'est pas
une agression pour prendre un sac ça moi
ma mère je la vois morte je l'ai déjà
dit dans un autre émission je la vois
morte ma mère
vous pensez quoi de tout ça vous
citer votre maman
c'était votre maman vous aurez fait quoi
parce qu'on a été on a été un peu
critiqué qu'on a dit sur les avait eu
devant
c'est normal sur le moment de la colère
comme disent sur Carla mais franchement
il y a de quoi mais si c'était pas un
moment je serais comme vous monsieur
mais voilà mais si je peux me permettre
il faut quand même trouver une solution
à ce truc là les gens ils osent plus
sortir
de trucs des immeubles ils osent même
pas se manifester ils osent même pas
venir dans les émissions comme ça parce
qu'ils ont peur de se faire agresser
après moi on me l'a dit on m'a dit t'as
pas peur de te faire agresser maintenant
mais je suis descendu à la boca à
l'autre soir des petits jeunes ils
étaient là qui me matté me brancher là
mais franchement
j'avais beaucoup de colère
parce qu'il faut que ça bouge bien sûr
frappé je suis tombé par terre il m'a
pris mon sac il est parti ils m'ont
laissé par terre et s'il y avait pas le
voisin qui me trouve et les pompiers
sont arrivés ils m'ont emmené à
l'hôpital 89 ans qu'est-ce que vous avez
à dire à monsieur le ministre
vous avez quoi au début je te parle
désolé
son jeune 14 ans mais après quand
j'étais très mal dans le dos j'ai dit
non j'ai pris la colère j'étais en
colère
[Musique]
combien de fois j'ai entendu des
policiers me dire on va les arrêter et
deux jours après ils vont être dehors on
aura sans doute l'occasion d'en parler
et moi-même j'entends ça et je le
comprends mais mais dans le cas précis
de Madame si je peux me permettre ils
ont été interpellés et ils sont
aujourd'hui toujours dans le centre
éducatif fermé d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on
en a 53 décembre comme ça pour les
jeunes il y en avait 6 il y a 15 ans
donc on essaie de prendre en compte ce
que vous dites mais moi je vais vous
dire quelque chose Monsieur c'est très
important l'autorité des parents il faut
quand même qu'on puisse dire on le dit
pas assez les parents sont responsables
de leurs enfants mais ce que je dis est
un seul je n'ai toujours dit d'ailleurs
le on a reçu le le père d'un
désagresseurs il est venu sur mon
plateau
et son père vous l'avez vu comme moi
vous voyez voilà c'est une famille avec
je crois il est plus venu pour sauver
son boulot que que pour des fin de son
fils en tout cas il a il a aucun
problème avec ses autres enfants et
c'est la presse qui dit voilà mais moi
c'est quand j'ai cet été je suis allé à
Mayotte à Mayotte si j'ose dire c'est
c'est dix fois pire il y a des enfants
de 12-13 ans qui est au couteau attaque
des policiers donc mais ça va Mayotte
comme partout sur le territoire j'ai
parlé d'encadrement militaire pour les
plus jeunes pas pour tout le monde mais
je pense qu'il y a un tel niveau de
violence dans une partie de notre
jeunesse une partie réduite une partie
quand même que quand vous avez des
enfants de 12 13 14 ans qui ont des
couteaux qui attaquent des vieilles
dames dans la rue
c'est pas simplement un accompagnement
social qu'il faut il faut faire serrage
de vis quand j'ai dit ça j'ai eu le
droit là encore à plein de il va trop
loin il va moi je pense je pense
vraiment parce que je veux dire quelque
chose les policiers les gendarmes il
faut bien être conscient de ça c'est
si quelqu'un fait un AVC ou une crise
cardiaque les urgentistes vont arriver
vont le soigner ils vont le sauver ils
vont pas le sauver et si le sauve c'est
pas pour sol de tout compte c'est parce
que ce monsieur qui a fait un AVC
peut-être que depuis 40 ans il fume il
boit il fait pas de sport il est très
stressé il a pas suivi des médecins il a
pas fait une bonne alimentation et
l'urgentiste va pas le sauver
profondément il va le sauver au moment
donné le policier c'est pareil quand il
arrive pour arrêter madame c'est c'est
sauvageons comme dirait Jean-Pierre
Chevènement c'est arrivé c'est
délinquant il y a pas d'autres mots ils
arrivent pour les interpeller mais voyez
c'est pas des policiers gendarmes qui
vont régler ce problème le problème
c'est l'école c'est parfois une
immigration balle contrôlée c'est les
parents qui ont pas d'autorité peut-être
que nous on met pas assez de
responsabilité aux parents c'est le fait
que un urbanisme parfois est très mal
fait la politique du logement n'ont pas
concentrée des difficultés partout en
même temps c'est la justice qui
peut-être n'a pas donné assez d'exemples
auparavant mais un atome
vous avez pu l'accueil le truc monsieur
le ministre plusieurs choses là qui sont
qui sont intéressantes et c'est vrai que
vous avez dit c'est aussi la
responsabilité de l'école des parents en
fin de les parents en premier les
parents en premier bien entendu et vous
avez dit j'ai dit qu'il fallait être un
vous dites depuis le début j'ai dit j'ai
dit telle chose j'ai dit telle chose on
met on met aujourd'hui c'est vrai que à
chaque fois que vous allez faire un pas
de côté on va vous tomber dessus parce
que il y a une ça c'est pas grave mais
ça il faut franchement ça je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les Français ils veulent
de la fermeté ils veulent que ça avance
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui moi je fais
une émission tous les soirs où je traite
d'actualité tous les soirs et tous les
jours j'ai l'impression qu'il y a eu un
drame tous les jours il y a des drames
qui arrivent en France et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui sont c'est fait par des des
personnes de plus en plus jeunes est-ce
que ces personnes ne se disent pas aussi
on a plus peur de la police on a plus
peur de voilà de l'autorité
ça aussi le vrai problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'ils
n'ont ils n'ont plus peur et ça va de
plus en plus loin aujourd'hui on voit
des jeunes de 14 ans qui ont des
couteaux qui sont armés aujourd'hui la
société d'aujourd'hui c'est pas la
société il y a 50 ans donc est-ce qu'il
faut pas aussi changer après vous n'êtes
pas ministre de la justice mais c'est
loi par rapport aux ados parce que
aujourd'hui il y a de plus en plus
d'ados qui commettent des crimes on peut
changer nomables on peut changer les
lois on peut améliorer évidemment les
choses d'un point de vue pénal mais
comme la très bien dit Monsieur lui-même
c'est pas en les mettant en prison à 14
ans on arrive parfois on sait pas la
solution
dans les écoles ils peuvent ils peuvent
même pas les trucs de travers ou qui
veulent les punir un peu ils sont
insultés ils sont je pense que ça je le
redire je le redire ici je vous avais
l'air d'écarter monsieur anodin d'Arona
les parents c'est un rôle essentiel bien
sûr si on met pas la responsabilité des
débuts sur les premiers responsables on
n'y arrive pas vous savez quand j'étais
mère on me disait la rue la rue est sale
sh c'est super mais c'est pas le
meilleur qui la nuit vient mettre des
papiers dans la rue si la rue SL c'est
bien qu'il y a des gens qui jettent des
papiers alors il y a des gens
réfléchissent un peu ils disent c'est
pas moi qui j'ai des papiers bah ça je
me doute quoi que quand j'étais mère
lorsqu'on me disait les gens se gardent
n'importe où dans l'école de mon gamin
quand je faisais lire la police
municipale pour verbaliser ça tombait
parfois bizarre sur le mec qui hurlait
dans mon bureau la veille mais moi c'est
pour 5 minutes bah oui c'est tout pour 5
minutes donc d'abord la société c'est
pas l'état qui décide le gouvernement
qui décide et rien d'autre moi je veux
redire ici que les parents ont une
responsabilité essentielle et qui
fonctionnait faudrait trouver on peut
réfléchir à ça moi par exemple dans le
drame de Pontoise je te rappelle cette
petite fille qui était renversée cet été
par un motocross mais bon
le monsieur a été arrêté interpellé et
et mis en détention provisoire parce que
cette fille elle est traumatisée
peut-être physiquement à vie c'est un
drame ignoble j'ai demandé au préfet des
le Val-d'Oise d'expulser la famille de
son logement social
et j'ai considéré que c'était les
parents puisque ce jeune était très
jeune que c'était les parents qui
étaient responsables aussi de ce
motocross alors il y a beaucoup de gens
qui m'ont dit mais les parents ils sont
pour rien moi j'ai été élevé il me
semble dans beaucoup d'ici entre entre
nous j'ai parfois fait des bêtises il y
a des parents qui m'ont rappelé et quand
le prof ou le policier me faisait de
remontrance j'en prenais une à la maison
voilà et donc je pense que il faut
redire qu'elle serait les pistes alors
ce que je vous dis moi je pense qu'il
faut généraliser les expulsions par
exemple des logements sociaux des
familles à problèmes on en connaît tous
des familles à problèmes je confonds pas
avec la dame seul qu'elle aime ses trois
gamins qui est très difficile pour elle
d'avoir un ado de turbulent là on doit
l'aider on n'est pas là pour lui
rajouter des problèmes mais il y a des
familles qui vivent des problèmes dont
on sait que l'ensemble de la famille vit
de vol de trafic de drogue mais le
bordel dans le quartier pardon de dire
autrement on peut pas continuer à donner
un logement social à ces gens-là donc ça
la loi de l'autorise j'ai demandé au
préfet de la République désormais de le
systématiser et je l'ai fait cet été et
qu'importe ce que disent les beaux
esprits parisiens après moi je pense
qu'il faut pour redire ça c'est très
très important et pareil on fait des
choses quand même je parlais des
urgences qu'est-ce qu'on fait en amont
moi je vais remercier Jean-Michel
Blanquer qui est un grand minis
éducation nationale ce que dans une
ville difficile comme pourquoi j'ai vu
ce que c'est d'avoir 35 gamins en CP de
diverses nationalités dont beaucoup de
parler pas bien français et commence la
transformation d'une école d'une classe
dans un quartier difficile quand on est
passé de 12 enfants par classe après 35
enfants par classe quand on a un prof
qui s'occupe de 12 gamins
et même quand les parents ont des
difficultés moi je peux vous dire qu'en
deux trois ans on a vu la différence
dans beaucoup d'endroits de la
République alors évidemment c'est très
long ça parce que les gamins qui sont en
CP aujourd'hui avant qu'ils aient 14 ans
il faut attendre 7-8 ans bien sûr donc
il y a un travail de parents et un
travail d'école il faut mettre beaucoup
des moyens sur l'école il y a un
triggerbanisme Borlo a fait un travail
formidable il y a beaucoup moins de
violence urbaines aujourd'hui vous
parlez de ce qu'on connaît qui a 20 ans
il y a 20 ans Nicolas Sarkozy mise à
l'intérieur il commentait la télévision
1000 voitures brûlées par jour le
sentiment qu'on a peut-être mais c'est
la réalité des faits mais il y a 20 ans
chacun se rappelle la bataille Sarkozy
Villepin peut-être 1000 voitures brûlées
par jour il y a pas 1000 voitures
et aujourd'hui on a fait un travail sur
les murs parce que ce sont des travail
sur les hommes je sais Monsieur le
Ministre mais avant il y avait deux des
gros événements comme ça enfin des gros
dérapages des gros là aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'il y a tous les jours
des voilà des des la petite délinquance
de la grosse
c'est pas chez le premier à dire qu'il y
a une crise d'autorité c'est ça je suis
premier à dire qu'il faut serrer la vis
comme on dit en premier mais il faut le
faire il faut pas écouter les bobos qui
vous disent vous savez les bobos ils
sont ils votent pas pour moi oui donc
ils sont pas chez moi
vous serez le président de tous les
Français
je suis pas candidat à la présidentielle
et je suis désolé c'est très c'est très
la grandeur d'être mise à l'intérieur et
tous les jours je mesure le poids de ma
responsabilité je pense que personne
n'accepterait que je pense à autre chose
plutôt que de protéger les Français mais
juste vous dire moi je m'en fiche des
critiques et donc on dirait-on on
critique et c'est normal c'est la vie
politique j'essaye de faire des choses
j'arrive pas toujours encore une fois
mais j'essaie qui n'essaye pas n'y
arrivent pas c'est sûr il y a que ceux
qui ont les compas demain qu'on les
mains propres comme dirait l'autre mais
ce que je peux vous dire c'est parfois
on gagne des batailles politiques il y a
un an et demi j'ai parlé de la double
peine vous savez c'est les étrangers qui
étaient condamnés en France quand ils
ont fait des crimes et des délits
aujourd'hui la loi les protège on ne
peut pas les expulser partant du
principe que ils ont déjà une première
peine la prison la deuxième peine c'est
l'expulsion pendant un an on a eu
beaucoup de débats là on va avoir une
loi qui va à force de le dire sur les
plateaux à force de le démontrer à force
de prendre la parole à me faire disputer
les uns et les autres on a une loi le
président de la République à valider qui
va supprimer cette double peine
c'est-à-dire que désormais à partir du
mois de janvier prochain parce que la
loi sera votée à partir de janvier tout
étranger Coralie un crime et un délit en
France sera expulsé en lui retira ses
papiers on expulsera aujourd'hui il y en
a plus de 3000 par an qu'on n'arrive pas
à expulser à cause de cette loi pendant
un an j'ai dit ça j'ai dit je porte ça
je pense ça et ben on a gagné ce combat
politique grâce au président de la
République donc ça sert à ça à faire de
la politique parfois c'est trop long
pour les gens je comprends 1000 c'est ça
c'est ça moi-même vous savez ça m'énerve
pour ça c'est long alors on va
parler il a enlevé
le maire de Cannes alors justement le
maire de Cannes le maire de Cannes il a
David Lisnard avait mis donc ce twitch
j'ajoute il dit que s'il avait été il
avait mis un tweet comme quoi
en essayant de ne pas me laisser aller
s'ils agissaient de ma mère qui avait
été ainsi agressée en connaissant
l'identité des mines d'auteurs de cette
abjection c'est peut-être moi qui sera
aujourd'hui en prison c'est vrai qu'il y
a de plus en plus de gens qui disent on
va se faire justice nous-mêmes et ça
c'est inadmissible et c'est vrai que
voilà il a parlé sur le coup de
l'émotion David Isnard et tout le monde
a compris ce qu'il voulait dire et tout
le monde voilà
je connais bien David star c'est un
grand-mère qui est d'ailleurs très bien
élu dans votre réagi comme lui mais j'ai
déjà réagi comme lui quand j'étais mère
je ne comprends pas je comprends très
bien ça alors quand on aimer on protège
sa population et il vous protège madame
moi je le comprends très bien enlever le
bac qui avait un bain pour travailler il
aura enlevé le maire de canne très bien
une histoire m'a demandé des CRS c'est
maintenant il y a des CRS ou peut-être
vous les voyez pas de fouiller en ce
moment même
un moyen
qui nous regardent certainement ce soir
en tout cas Angeles
je vous donne le bonsoir de David et
l'avocat c'est un quartier de Cannes que
dalidistar m'a fait visiter parce que je
fais plusieurs fois
c'est que vous soyez de retour et que
vous soyez en meilleure forme et là
c'est important merci d'avoir été là
[Applaudissements]